incredible
[Music]
and for cancer
john wayne state beer and excursion
[Applause]
light
and software that aroused interest in
august English is the language
[Applause]
extra
a
stage
before
d
yes
with the greens
hello
performance and stains  onstar el iscamén
joyner is the minimum set
madrid updated tension
the way for mexico el caminante and
william sound in their meetings of their
equal asked to finally be in
experience ok from princeton and mandy
soccer director of ripstein is first
in hesse wild wolf alicia garcíadiego
el  night
m
more
[Music]
in an interview on the
world with me accreditation
program foreign times
talks about latin america pro makers
shake metro bags after brotherhood of
nouns barry
eagerly practicing having an equality
hart albert stroni gray element makers
la  cumbia loses
the lord steve shelley the direct mobile
paul wix the pressures in water nateq
flores pre  sley between the sunday segment
of the times of spontaneity
chris volcano activity documentary film
maker
people but the matches don't turn out for me
[Applause]
great i like you
in the pot
hold the change to describe understand
is more the session the swamp of your hunger
in huesca
lucrecia martel  gameplay afraid
screening abroad they are carstens
am
leave me you may have had doubts between
the shows in trier sol de america they have
lost
the garfield show funding edition of
project
on the day of miss and mister me
device or this solar work
anderson many people in  world
in making it happen in many neither to be
serious the truth
am
[Music]
yes
the introduction in greece back in
favor of water and renault of the
mobility restriction cities artist
solutions were projectile in extending or
belongings to see it on the website drop  de
website emitted the future stress of
ribéry the negrín lumen and help us been
flat they stopped doing
[Music]
screenings in  Another type of crime to
lose
anyway is av
we don't explain
here
h
sarrià and sant andreu
[Applause]
Lucrecia martel de cama pie
a
en la carrera
[Applause]
and the English
thank you for coming
ansa my English yorwin
ah
Thank you for being here, he says his English
is very bad, well, welcome,
but you're happy to see your movie
after
how many years, the countryside, how many years
sixers, 16,
Lucrecia, we congratulate you because you've made
many other wonderful movies
after this one.
Now we have some questions.  that
we have prepared of course speaking
[Applause
] as Lucrecia
enters for me
don't write the projects she
has prepared some questions for
Lucrecia and she can hear very well without the
microphone herself well
he
asks her this in her first
feature film later  After having made
several shorts and he is very intrigued to know
how the genre, the story as he thought of it,
how it developed in his head,
in general, I was able to
The desire to film always arises from
fragments of dialogues, conversations such
as the path with fragments of
insects. I observed
on vacation I was in Salta and
my mother asked me to accompany her to see
the virgin that appeared in a water tank,
a true story fun show.
Its base is for Nissan.
peaks really should mary
jane apple the
time appears in some
unusual places instruments places in a
water drum and container of water
is a video
in a light bulb in the electric
light bulb in a steak inabif floor
so it is very common  It is not something that
one is going to see the virgin as something
jumping, really familiar, but hey, I
went with my mother
with a little fear because I did not have
the im  pressure that I was not going to see him
bersin mail
so we went we were stopped for a while it
was not a very strange situation
because there was a house of a family that
had a water tank and a lot of
people outside the poor family could not
even enter our house  situation
american girl in the house then
around the by people
and for a long time looking looking we looked
there were people who said in the tree others
said in the water tank
iberwine wilson from the chang of
water trio and looking there looking and at a
time that was very  exciting, my mother,
according to screams, fell to her knees and began
to cry when she saw the phone and they reap
point my mother health
neil wallis in standby what she was in and
it gave me a lot of emotion to see her so
moved and she told me the time to
show the  military movement my mother
things that in my abducted tuyú singer
and since I didn't see it I said need you have to
fix a little albert soler
provides the cloak
what to know what
is still a little bit when seeing
then  And that anecdote ended up
uniting
many things that I had been
writing that I didn't really know what they were,
that they were like fragments of situations,
family memories of friends, I
had been writing them down but I did
n't really know how to organize them and
that episode finished uniting everything a bit.
it is said pri software really from huaral to
forget this with exc wta the fragment
gibrán fin seraph thinking to right in
water belong to my child jordán the way
the wrap in salta and that basically is
how it was possible that in a in a
province in a region  where
the supernatural permanently the divinity appeared
as it was possible that it did not generate
any
change people
forgot supernatural
indians people reality did not generate
try following the know when
remember the joy one day I see the virgin
I think my life will change forever
always santa santa claus santa claus
schenk i
think britney spears motion production
but then
and that's
what i stopped  ció incredible is that
weather in which we are
not even something supernatural
allows a change you
expose your day and night
tussam say you understand is
and the story located in that region of
loving you
of this lourdes wants to ask
then how is it that this story that
Describes a little bit the environment of the
province of Salta that if Argentina is a
very special place
and Tomás is taking that into account or nothing else it
had a lot to do with your family Riley
having ambiguous faith and connected abroad
family joe jonas and you think it grew and it
is  Northern Argentina seemed to
bite.
I am not an expert in US history
or US
cultural diversity, but by the time
I presented dinner in different
places,
many people told me that there were some
similarities between  the south of the
united states and the north of argentina of
volleyball that they observe she was a
camping firmware the people
gerardo similar version it is between
hard  ware andar from american shows
argentina is a country that
perceives itself as a country of
immigrants ceimigra nation and perceives
bing immigrants but the north has a
very strong component of
indigenous culture from the north east version made
up of the indigenous calders
and as it happens in also  As happens in
any country where there is a diversity of
people and one group has better
jobs than the
other, something happens, racism is naturalized,
which is terribly,
and greatly deteriorates the sense of
community.
and the new haven installation of
summer season
break up a word I came back from normal
function and not fa community and that is
manifested in the language
well don't download everything but
in such a
deep way that it is difficult for an
Argentine to think
let's say that we Argentines
Let's think of Argentina as a
racist country and its decision is
born in
and on the internet bing I resist p  icos and julio
braun cannot do
that and the fact of being a catholic country,
at least officially catholic,
generates a whole series of contradictions
that let's say when I grew up not only
orders with projections we can impose and
little catholic thing between show with it is a
healthy contradiction  and crane can be
and a beautiful
place to bring a great place to bring pepe mel
i moved
but it's still a beautiful place and
she has made it real in her family are the
movies she has made to which
lucrecia answers tejar families really
the great  place to the so natural wrap
california it has been noticed so it jumps
that the blue berries are coming they are the blackberries
in which they will make them blueberries the
blueberries here in competition with chili
because at a time in that region not
so much in jump a little further south  In
Tucumán, a lot of lemon was produced and
then it seems that they stopped buying
lemon here, I don't know what happened,
and then the people of Tucumán and a part of
Salta began to produce blueberries,
please.  r do not stop buying blueberries from
tucumán
export
but the mind for them and so the switch
of blueberries
and weeps of 10 pixels are mixed birf and
lourdes and you are interested in knowing how is the
creation of the staging how
I imagine the scenes like the ones
organized
the truth that I learned from my work
after making this film
because at the time of making the night
let's not say like almost all of my
generation we didn't have a
film school but we learned by making
hitler shorts by doing work in first on your
life many people
generation about the i was with this
feeling
but what I do know is that it is always
easier for me to think about how
the scene is going to sound how I am going to see it how
the image is going to be rather the image is
as a consequence of the sound and the
sound that includes the dialogues
software/hardware really camps but if it
is from sound including the log show that
is here for three martín how the single
sound and then denzil 600 m3
and this is the advantage that it allows you to
save a lot of material because you don't have
to film so many sounds film
showmatch
6 material first
we wanted it to be asking want to
land from the beach swamp
and he actually applied it later
at dinner I did what  I could
and later I realized that it was the only
thing I could sell but the innervation
insisted on them so no
this
is not a bit when one talks about what
the directors actually do describe the work they
do
and the laser almost came much earlier  that he
a theory about cinema thinking
kreator will you you descend from
hunting about idem explained his honor to
be invited and I forced him to be
there which does not mean that there is no thought at all
but
[Music]
I don't know in fact it happened to me that  in the
fourth week of filming of the swamp the
producer sat me down in the hotel and told me
this film is not what i
imagined
australia indices is not filmed
4la stuart i came back and i was  There was a person
with a lot of experience in our being
and I thought about it and I believe, although in many
things he was right, but I told him I don't know, I do
n't know what to do, that is, if I don't do it, I
wouldn't know what to do, I can't,
as it seemed to him that the plans were  very
closed and that people were very
cold
I don't understand why
shooting close apps
[Music]
then
and I told him I don't know I'm going to have to
end it like this because I honestly don't know what to do
because I highly respected his
opinion I don't know what else  way I could
do it or they are
and well on the outside luckily later he
liked the review in city like
this moment like word in putting together and which ones did
you feel on autopilot at
some point
if it's a weird autopilot strange
one
I did something I don't know  yes this will be
the automatic pilot but as the only
fear that I had with the bond
on film first that we well, that is, I had already
assumed the fear that I did not know towards
the cinema so that it was going to be what I
could
after it has  There were many things that made me
ashamed that my family got
angry because it seemed like a lesser relationship
and then a very stupid decision was made
but it was very useful.
I decided to see several Fords that I
bought all my synthetic
clothes and I bought a lot of clothes  pants they use
on filming that were synthetic because
I felt that the more artificial
everything was, the better offer from Morcín
sur artificial and come back from acting
at the closer webber center and see see
artificial iii and now I'm going to launch a
clothing brand for filmmakers
[Applause]
audi ford filmmakers but it's good a
little fetishism that helped me distance myself and
distance myself from those temptations
that later I learned how to
distance myself by buying synthetic clothes
dancing leyton how to be pretty state
burnett necessarily in plain sight ipod
clouding but  luckily I don't
need it anymore,
but especially when you don't
have experience, you can confuse
cinema
as c  ierta book
the procedures of the cinema with the
truth
bonjour nin expired and senior big in you
can with fuse de presidio soft mechanics
or feel baking with cruz well then they
are
that is for me what fascinates me about
cinema is that it is all a lie anything goes
The law tells me
and that such an
artificial, liar construction
reveals things about the reality of an
artificial baby, construction by
Riley Steele Reville, reality was installed
and then the path was moving away from the
idea of ​​truth but rather going in search of
something else
[Music]
no  I know why I thought that with
synthetic clothes and looking for truth in
different versions indifferent of
interest cloud in word but health
one raffo
to finish loading story is nothing
the core is typical
hollywood lourdes is interested in knowing the
mechanisms are the way  that the
story was built if in some
way it was possessed by something and
observe lourdes that the construction of the
story does not follow the rules of a
classic hi  history what we would say
in the way of hollywood
my great this narrative school has been
the oral tradition that was exercised in my family
was fundamentally by
my grandmothers my mother
and she already won 9
in mother
that in my house it was the north in the
culture  from the north is very from the tales
of
to explain one thing in a long way
a bit a pleasure just get tired of
tradition player of long story explain
in everything in the district 9
extra hours now and such
that they don't really explain much and I do
n't know  it knows where they are going it is new
they are marching foreigners are television
island kayak stories and it is particularly
with the one assigned when and that happened to me
when I saw it finished I realized that it
was the same as how my mom talks on the
phone
wes welker subject choosing fauna but
but no  as one speaks on the
telephone now but the old telephone that
forced one to be still from old
fashion telephone is addressed to tobey
quiet standing talking
in my house I was in the
kirchner house kitchen and my mom in the kitchen
we did our homework so it
was a place where one could very easily
see my mom talking to my
grandmother for hours
in the kitchen víctor william we
homer from the show control y girar modern
talking tom harman therefore  hours
and there is a way in that
narrative construction that has the swamp
that is for me could perfectly be
a way of my mother telling the death
of a young person
seeing way my dessert list mind the
way my mother choc the bag  money and
play that she already knows what is the
end that is going to happen where what she
wants to tell but she starts organizing
the events in a very arbitrary way
trying to find some
justification where story bacci construction or
building the insect waiting to find
justification  train to make things that
are what are better in the organization
and knowing that there is not going to be
a reason for that than taking him
abroad  ro to the element of distortion, he's
really always thinking about interest,
but that's what I
always found very moving, it's that
enormous human effort
in this case
and exemplified by my mother
for trying to make sense of what doesn't
make sense software microsoft mobile
world we know that my teacher in your fan
sense human and go tussam sinde minor
java sense
I think that this is the structures of
oral narrative it is interesting that
first that anyone
who does not have a clear partition can exercise it
anyone can can going to that  that of
course a highly educated person
has many tools to converse
but no not
in art the ability to speak does not
depend so much
on how educated the person is
in tulsa and having religion
eduardo way you can't handle oral
narratives and the ability  poetics of
speech
exists even in the absence of the
hegemonic education of more standard
education education can really yus languages
poéti  ca reads
the language in the way and in any case
then it would seem that
the oral narrative power rather comes
from the experience of the existence of
a moon of a certain connection with one's
own experience
connection between experience is not authorized were of
capacities stories  oral and
and then
when I give why
and I give some workshops that are about
dialogues and about sound
what I like to do with my
classmates in these workshops is to
pay attention to those structures
because they are very original
[Music] they
are
accessible to anyone they are
around us because they are things that
people use
and
[Music]
and those are negative forms
that are sometimes despised by the most elaborate art
works inc
sound and keys sting
and apart from that it
is curious but that is a world that
women  They exercise the narrative with great enthusiasm
and less when seeing social good
is in favor of storytelling then
and as good so far I suppose
this ends tomorrow  na women have
been a bit run the scene of
power let's say in the culture
of centers or any discussion return
are interesting tradition among these
reports but it was a description
in 2006 points out it is a magnificent
description of the power of
non-mediated popular oral narratives
perhaps because of the culture and he hopes that
having film students here pay
attention to these observations and above
all my advice is always to young
colleagues that they study film makes
me very happy to say that
my age only allows me
226 emerging  and feel makers
that he
sometimes goes
to the cinema to film students
and I understand the reasons but it would
seem that the emergency is to see all the
cinema
that exists and of course it is
fabulous today it is a film school to see
cinema but
it seems to me  me that the the reason the
force what
leads us to make movies is what
surrounds us
and so
software neuer worth in texas artusi
everything w  ill have to be complete the
web what's going on and so we make up
within the
darwin place and observe branding
and what happens around ours
is very particular very singular and sometimes
it cannot be counted with structures or
narrative ailments observe that round
bieber and peculiar and different in sun
times
but nothing of excerpts from a fit club in
belo sorry
in which his departure will be
the order and thanks
but never we are for time
luis tosar time sell of the question
I see that it is that the wine
[Laughs  ]
the swamp in the subsequent peter films
presents taste of the company
between the spanish de criollos en
dientes le venirán después ese santo
indio explore
[Music
] lourdes is interested in asking then
if this dynamic between the indigenous and
the criollo of European Spanish origin  In
general, it is something that she has been
interested in exploring in other films. It
horrifies me, like when
in a community
there is this association of people of a
certain type.  smell with a
generally disqualified job and other people with
better jobs better access to
any benefit of society
what is generated over time that
livestand
good community split windows tour hub
of which those work
certain income for different
in the  long run keep a balance
william wright
and one can apply it to
anyone who exercises power in a
society in a couple in a family
to exercise it you also need to
weaken the other it seems that it is an
incapable structure or a show without liking vall
d'  albaida dynamic
and above all it
is terrifying how a group stops being able to
perceive the other storify one group can't
stop pershing standing guider and when
the other group reacts
with resentment with violence they do not
understand what the origin is software
when the group in power  wine generate
serbia kss jones and the rise and sell
23 james the group in power snow white
and stay and what happened and  So
, well, those mechanisms that are so obvious begin,
it seems to me that to dismantle they
need it
to be able to see them so we can talk to
be able to see again what surrounds us and
that is already so naturalized, we
need a lot of cinema, a lot of literature, a
lot of theater, a lot of solutions.  word audio
mind if the situation is normal that
audio from and how you can am so that
they give you
in the other films in the holy girl it
was only like focusing on
a small aspect over a
situation of abuse
rather of a sexual nature
and how  that certain details around
that are from hollinger file without trading
show in that power situation forced me to
be constant
lips in the world the beatles all that
situation and in the case of the headless woman
is that phenomenon that in
argentine society we had
horrifying decades of example of
how a class protects itself and
I know
how it protects itself so as not to
take responsibility for things I am lie de
jardín
grisanti system argentina interest in
the head the woman in looking at dawn
social group protect cels in order another
responsible film ford must be happen
that society
and also because I am talking about
a society with a
deeply Catholic culture and the problem of
Catholicism is  that
a good way to get rid of
responsibility
was by inventing guilt myself in argentina
for explanations
nation one way of working 16 of
responsibility is the wild
what
because the difference between guilt and
responsibility
seems to me to be that guilt
exonerates us from doing  things
william responsible for ree exonerates him
from frank wind star trophy free for
a says oh what a horror what a fright
efe well we are going to do something else with
simple letters and instead
responsibility forces you to be
responsible
forster 211
and when I say this it is not that  I think that
the Protestant countries or of other
religions this does not happen
better you down the world with you but
What I do believe that this is the luxury and the
privilege that the power that
cinema has is that we can
and use that powerful tool to
observe each one of their society and try
to detect
how
certain horrible things are
naturalizing their film power and soul
soul house and nicole be your look in
tweets the show your normal and without
stressing be normal
so
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much
and also
[Applause]
lucrecia sin despertar interviews of the
pacific standard time
program lourdes coordinating for water
for hours
granma
website
the talk of san fermin and hours
[Applause]
x